thank you
[Music]
so it's official uh we've talked about
it before but now motions are being
moved Congress introduces a bill to ban
Tick Tock over spying fear do you think
so that's gonna really happening we
never know if it's actually tick tock's
done I don't know they're gonna put like
I mean our phone's already spying on us
so like what are they worried about yeah
but it's okay if they spy on us yeah
they want China to spawn yeah they want
International come on [ __ ] I was
looking down with the little camera was
like I think someone's watching it
it's like I even said I was like I think
someone's watching me like I had the
camera
because I know you're good you're good
you're good where's his eyes
he tries to go back to being an ad want
to play a game
granny's in your area guaranteed you
won't last 30 seconds
oh dude it does pretty well that's they
almost got me once I'm like [ __ ] I
can't
sounds like a challenge yeah I know I
was like [ __ ] the big booty [ __ ] I was
gonna watch definitely trying this 27
seconds later [ __ ] a loss yeah close all
right sorry so uh Trump try to ban Tick
Tock yeah he did right that was one of
the things because China but it didn't
work it didn't go through or I think it
was but then the first time around it
was for a different reason I think now
they have hard evidence that there's
like actual spying and data collection
so now they're trying to hit harder
members of the House and Senate have
introduced matching bills that would
block transactions from any social media
company in or influenced by China Russia
Cuba Iran North Korea or Venezuela app
called Dick doc dick talk what's that
like a penis doctor it's just no yeah
yeah it's Tick Tock but American I mean
let me see how you're doing over there
Sunday yeah that's a normal pimple yeah
it's not herpes let me see that bad boy
Jesus Christ smallest thing I've ever
seen thank you dick doc thank you
the anti-social CCP act averting the
national threat of Internet surveillance
oppressive censorship and influence and
algorithmic learning by the Chinese
Communist party
yeah
well you know but they try to they try
to [ __ ] make the those acronyms work
like so anti-social like averting the
national threat of Internet surveillance
oppressive censorship and influence like
they're they're really trying to fit
what does that that make anti-social
whose job was that they can trick
they're probably like killed it they
need acronyms like that we don't right I
think antisocial we get it it's how
nerds talk well they don't they want
codes and [ __ ] but it's easy
accepting the turtle I'm like what the
[ __ ] they're LARPing bro yeah it's it's
meant to shut down access to tick tock
and other apps that could theoretically
funnel American user data to oppressive
governments censor news or otherwise
manipulate the public
I wonder what China's uh pocket move is
because I feel like they saw this coming
miles away yeah so I feel like they have
a thing where they're like it's a
contingency okay now they're America's
gonna do this now all right we already
got Plan B I feel like something worse
is coming yeah speculate what would you
say they're like Americans cannot resist
the twerking on a tick tock Oh They'll
fight for it that's what they said yeah
that's what they talk it's like there's
no way they're gonna let us cancel
because I feel like The Leverage Works
in an interesting Direction Where so
much of a seemingly American [ __ ] is
also Chinese owned yeah but then it's
not publicly known that way so it's kind
of a thing where they have controlling
interest in certain things that if they
so wish to tighten the fist on it they
could do it in an instant they just
don't because of relations do you think
Americans will give major pushback if
Tick Tock gets banned Americans I think
like no Young Americans yeah that's what
I mean I think they'll create something
else let's go to the next thing like you
know I'll tell you what dude I wasted a
lot I wasted China's time with my [ __ ]
the algorithm you wasted their server
space video they didn't get nothing from
me this guy likes big booties that's all
we got
this guy like watching cooking videos
and big booty shaking that's it I'm
thinking it's a political for me and
[ __ ] I just skip to that [ __ ]
let's get to the ass well that's that's
one of the theories right they're trying
to uh distract us as well right the
algorithm is so good being distracted
though dude
before China came into the picture you
know what I'm saying like television
distracted me
well yeah the theory is that it gives it
gives younger Generations like shittier
aspirations of what to become right
that's been America though yeah welcome
dude but Tick Tock is another level of
like how people are hooked on it like
even it is pretty yeah like I see like I
try to stay away from it because I know
if I get hooked on it I'm not gonna do a
[ __ ] damn I never got hooked on it
dude I'm really I'm [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] every day I gotta look at
her every five minutes sometimes I I
look up and I'm like I wasted a whole
day you know what's crazy it went on
apps like this there's the moon again
I'm literally I'm doing this I'm this
guy here oh wow it's crazy it's also
that remember that tricky thing I was
telling you about how like staring at me
if I don't if I don't use the tick tock
it doesn't get as many vehicles in views
on the content you're uploading wow
people have said that for a long time I
don't know if it's true for everybody
but I have checked it on hours and it is
true for that like sometimes if I'm not
if I don't use it actually as a consumer
yeah then the numbers are lower on the
views coming to to the interest so I
just leave it on lives and I just put my
phone inside do some other [ __ ] and then
the numbers are always a little bit
better wow wait wait wait wait what yeah
because apparently I don't know if it
might just be a [ __ ] uh yeah it might
be Placebo thing but they say like if
you if you're using it a lot as a user
then you get rewarded as people watch
your [ __ ] too
so if you're not getting hits you might
not be using the app enough that kind of
makes sense they want you to be in the
community yeah because it it shows
you're active in it it's like oh this
guy uses it I watch it but I never put
[ __ ] on it that's my [ __ ] problem I'm
gonna post it I'm like nah flash for
[ __ ] weirdos dude
and you're just consuming shitloads of
it
I'll try like flipping the other side I
should try and see what China's up to
you know
I think I want to think you're trying to
fool them
this Jesus guy no I'm looking at this
you know haha you got me [ __ ] how would
you like to come to Shanghai
your mind is very interesting
the thing about Tick Tock is I never
like want to go on Tick Tock you just
like you know button press through your
different apps you just end up there and
the next thing you know you're scoring
and then next thing you know you're
scoring and the next thing you know it's
a drug yeah right like it's too good bro
that's what it comes down to and it's
like a bunch of like like 89 [ __ ] 90
useless [ __ ] but it's fun there's some
[ __ ] that you're like how the [ __ ] do
they think of oh speaking of Texas so
funny so some of them are just like dude
they're so creative hey have you heard
about this gun have you heard about this
guy on Tick Tock that's been going crazy
his name is Rudy Valencia Rudy Valencia
so there's just this random guy that
like my sister-in-law showed me and he
got caught cheating yeah with some like
his I think he's like housekeeper or
like his like babysitter yeah in the
back seat of his car and the gr his baby
mama filmed him yeah and they were like
this girl it's his girlfriend she was
just like
Valencia I can't believe you're like you
know and she opens the door and catches
the girl
but the [ __ ] ain't a prize you know
what I mean that [ __ ] has a gut on her
[ __ ] kangaroo pouch
no [ __ ] baby she's just [ __ ] it's
a Taco Bell burrito baby you know what I
mean dude this video got 16 million
views is it so funny because it's funny
because
her [ __ ] out right sponsors out and
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is
everywhere it's dude it's hilarious and
I heard about it I was like I kept
asking like who
and she'll be watching tick tocks and
they'll say Rudy Valencia and I'll be
like who the [ __ ] is Rudy Valencia he
but the thing is that he gets [ __ ]
called out and then she [ __ ] slaps
but he does the typical like you know
when your little kitty get hit when you
know you did something wrong but you try
to make that hit feel like it was worse
than what it really was because he
barely nipped him and he's just like
he like like he shut down he's selling
it bro he shut down he's gonna get a red
car right now yeah is that camera
like now he can't even think he's like
he's playing up the foul let's see if I
can pull up like that was like I was
like really bro that was like a baby
little [ __ ] slap but he made it tick
tock and his dude is going viral like he
has a following now everyone's [ __ ]
with this dude
one from it he's gonna be like the Ocean
Spray dude keeps like [ __ ] like he
has a history of like cheating all the
time so it's like this wild Saga that
everyone keeps coming out bro the lady
they got caught in the back seat she got
her own Tick Tock she has a phone like
it's crazy bro yeah pull it up and
that's why I was curious I was telling
Novella [ __ ] bro
um
I gotta flip it around yeah I'm trying
to pull this back shorts doesn't let you
do that
once you like start it a little bit you
can't [ __ ] go back on anyways
wow look at that [ __ ] what I can't
see maze man look he's hiding from the
thing yeah
oh wow yeah they look like they're at
the [ __ ] park down the street yeah
dude look look look
dude I have to go to work
yeah baby oh I've been there Rudy
Valencia oh damn
how are they doing it like that she's in
the back seat and he's in the front well
I guess like he saw her come up and he
just [ __ ] jumped out and then she was
just like putting her pants back on and
if you open the door she cut her with
the gut out and like she tucked then
that lady was just [ __ ] did that
penguin Walker so now this foil is
getting more famous and apparently the
girlfriend that filmed he cheated on he
he was with some other chick and it
hooked up with the girlfriend yeah she
was like uh so he's been hopping all
around so he's been he's been out here
he's been a cheater Rudy Valencia is a
little [ __ ] yeah Rudy Valencia is a
[ __ ] R Kelly song and I mean he's
just out here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]